we'll take five suggestions and then uh
we'll do this you put a hand up which is
so polite i love it yeah i love you like
at hip-hop concerts what do they say put
your hands up yes i'll do that uh hello
what would you like a rap about
vaginas cool that's a very broad topic
obviously that's not a criticism of the
size of vaginas that was a
misspoken sentence there um
vaginas very broad but let's be more
specific so let's hone in let's you know
like the effects of cranberry juice on a
vagina or you know mismatched labia and
how that's perfectly normal and not
something to be worried about but not
those because i've already suggested
them
there's so many topics to do with
vaginas you can trust me don't it's not
like a test i'm like i don't think he'll
know anything about this no go go for it
someone else can help you out if you
want i feel like
what was that
a hairy vagina lovely a voluptuous
follicular vagina
you were going to say that we didn't
want to say you could have mimed it
there you go that would have been fine
um so uh a hairy vagina lovely that's a
great first suggestion for a sunday you
absolute animals
uh if you're in kind of these these
little tables here storming all the
it's the storming of old trafford that
sounds like a battle from a thousand
years ago but what happened today
manchester united were due to play
liverpool in the northwest derby and um
a lot of manchester united fans occupied
the pitch and they had to postpone and
then later call off the game and i
imagine that you was very annoyed so i
was quite looking forward to it and i
did get up in time for the kickoff there
we go no one else is going to enjoy that
bit but hairy vaginas and the storming
of old trafford middle of the room if
you're in this kind of area what you
want to rap about
aliens playing virtual reality you said
aliens playing virtual reality i like
that thank you someone over there made a
kind of expression as if to speak what
were you going to say
internal combustion engine internal
combustion engine yeah do you have a
particular vehicle that you want that in
oh
an aston martin great okay and then
people over here what you want to hear a
rap about
stinky balls stinky balls good
this then lovely people is going to be
yeah it's going to be a wrap a freestyle
right made up on the spot based entirely
on those suggestions if we can drop that
beat good sir that'd be delightful the
storming of old trafford a hairy vagina
an internal combustion engine aliens in
virtual reality and stinky balls were
able to press play on that track yes and
do not worry guys it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curlingly bad as
you're expecting a privately educated
middle-class white british boy to be
i'm very excited to end the show this
way even if all of you seem totally
unconvinced this is gonna be great we'll
start off with that one because i think
that's the one you know least about okay
you gotta trust the facts i'm spitting i
hope you all believe 149 years ago
newton heath was the name of a team
built by a foundry now in the present
2021 the glazers that's american family
they came in they thought they'd be
handy using all the financials but they
drew out all the profit and people now
they're sick to the hindi they say stop
it avram you need to back off so they
went on the pitch on the hello turf they
broke through the turnstiles by the
dressing room we couldn't get football
in the afternoon that one guy's nodding
he's feeling the shorts saying yeah he
really nailed the storm and obviously
thought it only happened today this was
meant to be between you and me a topic
so contemporary but that's okay maybe
it's just in my mind i got an oculus
quest i use it to unwind put it on my
head my eyes look like a car like i'm
driving when i'm in the vr i'm not
saying i'm an alien i'm a homo sapiens
but if i go out to outer space i'll be
facing them and saying guys you want to
do this a favor you can get controllers
and play beat saber they'll be blown
away they're like my gosh this is really
great i wanna buy vr i say other things
to their little green face you could
pretend you're in a car in first place
in a race they're like wow i'm really
starving for the experience of aston
martin driving chris can you give me
some instruction cause they don't
understand internal combustion they use
magnus they use nuclear power but if
you've got a little time let me break it
down for you in the 50s martins were on
the freeways everybody starting used to
use a crack about 30 years before but if
you pop the hood inside then you would
have saw a little piston set going all
around but if you're in germany they
don't use the pound they use the euro
they have a vancl rotary engine it's
different slightly well i really should
mention always used is the spark from
the plugs i know this is not what you
expect from this thug from the uk you're
like all right me old china rap about
that airy vagina of course i will it
doesn't matter if it's long if it's like
the amazon forest with all of the frogs
well if there's crabs or other animals
in there my main advice would be to
shave off your hair i say please guys
trim it down this time maybe get a
reference from your obgyn
it doesn't matter if it's shaved or it's
waxed if it's coming out you fly when
you open it about it's creeping out
there like the tendrils of the ivy
whether it be hairy whether it be shiny
i don't mind even if it's a little bit
smelly even if it's sweaty after you've
been doing ballet but one thing that
always appalls me if i'm a urinal if i'm
in a store see a guy next to me and i'm
like yo yo you need to get some wipes on
the side of your balls why they so
smelly what is all the scent it's really
horrible and the guy i know i meant well
saying he should take a shower more
frequently why cause there's little dick
cheese and it's seeping free out of the
side he's got to use the shower gel why
because his balls may be smelling after
high heaven high health it smells
something satanic that's a freestyle rap
i hope all of y'all understand it we
didn't plan it and it started with the
football and ended over there with the
horrible stinky balls
[Applause]
thank you very much you guys are
delightful